i again welcome all of you for this
webinar
on uh chemo informatics for biomedical
drug discovery
so as you know we have already started
uh
a four months intensive program of which
we have come we have completed genomics
model and
our transfer transcriptomics model is
going on and
from the 12th of june we are starting a
data science program and again from
14th of june we are starting a drug
discovery program
so this data science and drug discovery
program is
uh will go up together i mean
one can in enroll for a data science and
a drug discovery
both the program or either of any any
available program
so for this four months intensive
industry oriented program
we have several partners as uh sonalika
said but yes for
this drug discovery program we have
schrodinger with us
who will help students to uh for various
drug discovery aspects of
all also molecular dynamics molecular
modeling
techniques and molecular docking
practical experience on all those
molecular docking and dynamic stuff also
schrodinger have committed to provide
around four weeks of license for uh for
for uh training purpose those who have
those who are enrolling into this
particular program
so as so straddinger they are actually
a software company uh
into a molecular modeling and drug
discovery space
so they are they are a computational
structure based training and explicit
molecular dynamics they will be working
they are working on and they'll deliver
a talk talk on
the topics they would like to cover are
like master
gui gui they will cover how we can
sketch organic molecules how we can
select a protein how we can prepare a
protein
how we can do screening of heat
identification of a molecule against
various therapeutic targets molecular
mechanics dynamics talking
etc
so for this program we we have several
expertise uh
we have dr ajithi kamat from uh he's an
advisor at pandora technologies we have
chakra mesha who is a
faculty as you know university of
california we have doctor uday saxena
uh in next couple of minutes you would
meet him and
so he's a co-founder and region
co-founder of region biosciences and
he's a professor as well so we have dr
ramy reddy he's a founder and chief
scientific officer at national labs usa
and we have dr punet kakar he's a drug
discovery scientist from accenture
uh we also have us uh team members from
schrodinger
british bhatt uh prajwal ajit abhinav
devaraji kaushik and kishore from
ashford injured
so let us begin from a session
so as i mentioned uh we are starting our
session
uh 14th 14th we have one more free
webinar but actual session is actually
starting from the 15th of june
so on a 15th or 15th of june you will
learn
about the basics of chemo informatics
what exactly chemo informatics how you
can use this chemo informatics in your
day-to-day life
and for your day-to-day research work so
we will at
our expertise uh he they will teach you
how the introduction of the kim
informatics what are the databases
available
uh small molecule databases protein
databases
how we can calculate structural
properties of a molecule
how we can draw draw structural
molecules uh
what are their softwares available for
drawing a molecule and for visualization
of a small molecules and also protein
molecules
and then we have another session at 17th
of june
uh the topic would be ai in molecular
drug discovery here
in this in this session you will learn
how what is the big data in the chemical
domain or in a chemo informatics domain
how we can how we can access that data
how we can
automate that data using a programming
let's say python programming
uh how we can represent those molecule
into different
uh different structures uh in a
different way
you you will learn about it
uh we uh you will also learn
overview of application of ai in
structure and drug
structure based drug design and a
ligand-based drug design
and also i will highlight some of the
virtual screening steps
what you can do for a virtual screening
we have another session that is the
third session on a 19
june this could be a very intensive
session
we will start this session from a 10 10
am to
evening 4 pm wherein entire schrodinger
team
would be available to guide you and help
you for your
all all your aspect in this in this
session
just a minute guys
yeah so uh as i said this is a entire
one day uh session entire day session uh
so here you will learn many things about
structure based drug designing
like uh you will get to know how master
works how uh master you
how you can use master gui how to
do ligand preparation and how to
calculate admi properties using maestro
or using schwedenger
uh you know to to start with a drug
discovery
or a drug development process the very
the very beginning point is you know
protein preparation
and uh if you need to find out a
molecular if you need to do
docking study so definitely you have to
create a great generation so
the entire team will help you out to to
do all these steps what are the
parameters which are essential for the
protein preparation
what are the uh what are the
care of what all other cares we need to
take care
uh while during protein preparation how
to analyze protein
whether we have to remove water
molecules or not whether we have to keep
uh those integrated ions or not
everything everything will be guided by
our mentors and also we'll go ahead with
the molecular docking with the
schrodinger package or and also we'll
will have a session on analysis of those
talking results
so everything will be on a hands-on
session along
along with the practical and also will
have some theoretical sessions
and again on 20th of june uh we have
this could be a
fourth session for our program and we
have morning 10 a.m to 4 00 p.m
come at the entire day program here uh
the participants will uh our
participants will learn about molecular
dynamics using basemont
uh the the topics which we cover are
like you know desmond introduction a
theoretical
introduction of a desmond then we'll
have a practical demo on a molecular
dynamics how we can perform molecular
dynamics for
drug and protein and then we'll have
dismount trajectory visualization and
dismount molecular stimulation analysis
and also organic molecules enumerations
for the entire day from morning 10 am to
evening 4 pm
uh on 22nd of june
uh as a part of our fifth session we'll
again we'll jump into
several freely available software so in
the entire program
we have made like we will use
schrodinger and also we'll use several
freely available softwares to
to work on so in uh in the fifth session
we'll work on a molecular modeling steps
like we will work on
modulus space model for a homology model
homology modeling and other molecular
modeling steps we'll also do some gene
or protein analysis
like binding site analysis prediction uh
those are
some modification of those genes and
gene sequence and protein sequences and
also will
learn something about cellular location
and disease health condition
we have a sixth session on 24th of june
wherein we'll explore several
databases could be a chemical databases
or a protein databases
so uh we we have several materials
too and we have several uh python code
to extract data from a pubchem
as you know pubchem is the world's
largest collection of freely available
chemical information
or a small molecule information uh
database came spider is also
another database for small molecules and
chembel has been
is also a small molecule database which
contains
a curated uh molecules of bio
curated biofuel molecules along with a
drug like properties
so along with this databases you will
also learn
a pdb database other and other
gene and a protein sequence database as
well
as a part of sixth session as a part of
second
seventh session once we explore chemical
database and uh
protein database then we will we will do
again
practical hands-on docking using a auto
dock or auto dock vena
so the entire session is dedicated for a
practical uh
docking a docking on a docking of a
small molecules to the uh
or to the large molecules and this could
be a flexible docking this could be a
rigid docking
and we will work on your problems as
well and also will help you out how you
can analyze those docking results
and how you can you can take forward
those docking studies in your further
research
as part of session 8 which we will
conduct on
first of july will the the topic would
be target identification virtual
screening
so we will will you will have an
exposure to
the various methods for target
identification and validation and
will have some hands-on workshop on a
computer-aided virtual training so this
session has been done by
chakra mesha and dr punet
and then we'll have some advanced chemo
informatics topics and then again
also hands-on session for uh how you can
convert
heat to lead as you know entire truck
discovery process
so initially will will you will learn
how you can generate those leads and
then again how you can
convert those heat into lead and again
how we can
optimize those leads for further for
further our research process
so everything could be hands-on session
and uh we will mostly focus on freely
available tools so that you can use
those tools in your research work and
you can publish the paper
using those tools
and then again uh on 12th of july we
will
have session from schrodinger
and you will learn about free energy
perturbation what are those binding
energies what are those
uh bonds which are chemical bonds uh
physiological i mean uh ionic bond or
you will learn about all those
bonding uh bond between two atoms and
energy between the energy for those
binding
energy of those binding uh atoms and
also we'll have some
uh case study uh on an industry
application uh
so we have focus mostly on
the part like the current research is
happening in an industry
so we will teach you or will guide you
what exactly industry is working on
and then uh we'll have a practical
session on a game suit game suit is a
chemo informatics package wherein if
someone doesn't have a knowledge of
machine learning or chemo informatics or
a data science
still he can build machine learning
model or a deep learning model using a
game suit
so and he can do lot of chemo
informatics stuffs like descriptor
calculation
data set dividation normalization of a
data
and then analysis and prediction of a
newer data so
you will have you will you are you
actually you
you will get a chance to work a hands-on
session
on a game suit
uh again we'll have on a 14th of july we
have a session
on a session by dr salu
how we can apply our for our as in chemo
informatics to laura
the the entire session would be of again
practical session
uh so you will have uh so if you
if you don't know r we will help you out
uh to to learn r and you can do lot many
things using our in a chemo informatics
space
and you can automate many of your steps
using our programming language
on 20th of july we have a session
by dr ajit v kamat from pandora
technologies uh he'll talk on
recent advances in a drug discovery what
exactly happening in this drug discovery
area and where industry is looking for
in the future you will learn everything
from him on 20th of july
on 22nd of july we have a
talk on talk by professor uday saxena
he's the co-founder of region
biosciences
and he'll talk on a phase one to how we
can how the pharmaceutical company go
for phase one to nda submission and he
will give a case study on example of
successful and failed
uh drug using a failed drugs for a drug
discovery or drug development process
so so in the entire session you will
learn many things about drug discovery
from a
industry expert across the globe